>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> John Hessler: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I want to welcome all of
you to the Kluge Center.
Many of you are Kluge scholars
so you don't have to be welcomed
to the Kluge Center, you're
already at the Kluge Center.
But this is for the Kislak
Fellowship Annual Lecture.
This year's fellow
was Frauke Sachse.
She is the professor of Mesoamerican
Studies at the University of Bonn.
But she's a lot more than that.
The description, professor
of Mesoamerican Studies
doesn't really go far enough.
Frauke, at least in my estimation,
is one of the premiere linguists
working in the world right now
on a small group of languages,
many of them that are endangered.
Her dissertation focused on a
particular language called Szinca.
It is an extremely endangered
language that only a few people
in the world have worked on.
Frauke used 18th century grammars
in order to reconstruct what
that language looked
like, how it was spoken.
She spent many years in the field
doing field work to mixed success,
being there were few speakers who
actually could speak the language.
Since her dissertation,
she's continued work on that,
but she has also focused on
other Mesoamerican languages.
The area that we are talking
about, which is this small area
in Central America, is one
of the most linguistically
dense in the world.
Just in the Maya languages alone,
depending on who you talk to,
there are anywhere from 30 to 36
languages that are currently spoken.
She's going to speak to us
today about her Kislak project,
which she's also working
on with another researcher whose
name is Gary Sparks who's also
in the audience, about a manuscript
that is pretty much pretty unknown
in the Mesoamerican Studies world.
And Frauke and Gary have
made extreme inroads
into discovering what
may turn out to be one
of the most important manuscripts
in the Kislak collection.
So without further ado, Frauke.
>> Frauke Sachse: Thank
you very much, John.
It was a very kind, far
too kind, introduction.
I hardly recognize myself.
I would like to start this
with a couple of thanks.
Thanks, first, to the Kluge
Center, the Kislak Foundation,
for wanting me with this fellowship.
I would like to thank my
recommenders Nancy Ferris
and Kris Lorne-Trexloff [phonetic]
for helping me get this fellowship.
I would like to thank the
staff of the Kluge Center,
in particular Mary Lou Reker
and Travis Hensley have been
tremendously helpful and full
of support and assistance.
I would like to thank you,
John, for your great support
and assistance during this research.
And the entire staff of the
geography and maps department.
As you already said, the
project is not my own project.
It's a project that I'm doing
together with Gary Sparks
from George Mason University.
So all the work and all the
results I'm going to talk
about today are collaborative.
This is not only my achievement,
this is our joint achievement.
So I'm, we are working on this
manuscript in the Kislak collection
for which I received this wonderful
fellowship and Gary has been able
to do this research
based on any-age funding.
So we are both tremendously
grateful for the support.
The plans, what we have plans
for, various publications
which are coming out of this
research that we're currently doing
and I'm going to tell you a
little bit about this today.
For once, we hope that
we can produce an edition
of the entire document that
is in the Library of Congress,
a proposal for this is
currently under revision here
at the publications department
and of course we are very,
very hopeful that this is going to
be seen as an interesting project
and maybe get some support.
So, what are we talking about here?
Why is this not working.
Can somebody help me?
It's not working.
That one?
>> Yeah.
>> Frauke Sachse: Ah, okay.
So, we are talking about
a 16th century manuscript,
it's a hand book, that was used by
a missionary in highland Guatemala.
And these kinds of handbooks were
called [foreign term], "go with me,"
a little like what we have
today is a Moleskine handbook,
a little handbook that
contained various doctrinal texts
and other documents and textual
materials that were relevant
to this particular missionary
for his missionary efforts.
And it's particularly interesting
because it contains a collection
of different texts and
different Mayan languages
from highland Guatemala.
I would like to give you a little
bit of background information.
Highland Guatemala is the
world's second region,
or the second major region, that
was conquered by the Spanish
on the American continent in 1554.
The K'iche' speaking kingdom
of Utatlan was the main power
in this ethnically
and linguistically very
diverse Maya highland region
and as John has pointed out already,
there are many different
Mayan languages
that are still spoken
today and just in Guatemala
in this region we have
21 Mayan languages
that are spoken to this very day.
So one-third of the Guatemalan
population today speaks a Mayan
language, something that
is not very well-known.
From the beginning,
Christian-ization, the mission,
the conversion to the
Christian faith,
took place in the indigenous
languages.
And a particular role was played
by Bartolome de las Casas,
the so-called "Defender of the
Indians," who ended the bloodshed
of the conquest, which
was particularly violent
in highland Guatemala, by
replacing the sword with the gospel
and successfully pacifying the
resisting providence of Tezoatlan,
by reaching to the indigenous
population in their own language.
Guatemala is therefore one of the
best areas to study the encounter
between pre-Colombian and European
religions and word systems,
because there was so much missionary
documentation and so much material
that was produced by
these missionaries
in these indigenous languages.
And mostly, for the most part,
this material has been neglected
by researchers and there's
now a small group of people,
more and more research of
linguist theologians, historians,
becoming more and more
interested in doing work
with these missionary text
documents in indigenous languages.
And the Kislak manuscript 1015
is one of the earliest specimens
of such missionary or
doctrinic text documents.
It is, as I already said, a
compilation of various texts
and different highland
Mayan languages.
And all of these texts in
this manuscript are copies
of even earlier originals
that were copied or compiled
and then newly bound for the purpose
of this particular missionary.
Some pages were also deleted by
the binding, after the new binding,
and we can also see
that some pages were cut
out by whoever was
using that document.
We see a picture of a cut out page.
But we cannot say very much about
the binding and the paper yet other
than we know it's all 16th century
because the analysis of the paper
and the watermarks are something
that is currently being undertaken
by the conversation division
of the Library of Congress
and we are looking forward
to getting these results.
So the document, or the manuscript,
consists of various texts
by different scribes and copiers.
We can define different hands, you
can see them here numbered from A
to F. The compilation of the texts
is rather eclectic, one must say.
They are of very diverse origin
and of particular interest to us
as Mesoamericanists, are various
sections of Mayan numerals
or numbers, lists of numbers, there
are also sections of Latin numerals.
There are prayers in Latin
as well as catechisms
in K'iche' and in Kaqchikel.
And the core texts include several
sections done by the same copiers
or by the same hand, which is hand
number F, which include the text
"Cosas de la Fe Catholica,"
or in English,
"Things of the Catholic Faith,"
a text labeled [foreign term],
which is K'iche' for "Music."
And another section which is
called "Sermones," or "Sermons."
There are further texts that are
also done by that same copyist,
which is texts for the prerequisites
of marriage, a list of contents
of the proceeding texts
in the core texts section,
and further marriage
prescriptions and taboos,
I will come to that later
because that section's
particularly interesting.
So what have we done so
far with this manuscript?
In the fall, we produced a full
transcription of the entire book.
Which now amounts to, the entire
book itself, has 100 folios written
on both sides and in
the transcription,
that amounts to 150 pages, Times
New Roman, 10 point, single-spaced.
So it's a lot of text
that we are going through.
It's all in these indigenous
Mayan languages, so we have a lot
of translation work ahead of us.
We are now working on the textual
analysis of these sections and are
in the process of preparing
several publications.
Besides the manuscript edition
that we would like to do,
we are planning a detailed
translation of this core section
on the "Cosas de la Fe
Catholica," which I will talk
about in more detail today.
And we are working on an
article about the numbers section
and the marriage rules,
which are also topics
that I will be talking about.
Let's look at dating the
volume, how old is this really?
It's a bit tricky.
The document, I mean the handbook,
itself is clearly 16th century,
the handwriting is 16th century,
the binding is 16th century.
So far, that' clear.
There are two references
in the handbook
to a compilation date of 1567.
The core section includes,
core section of this "Songs"
that I will be talking
about, ends in a colophon.
And the text preceding this
colophon indicates that the copyist
or scribe completed the copy
on the 23rd of July in 1567
in the Valle de Panchoy, which
is today Antigua, Guatemala.
And this particular date of
1567 is repeated further below
in this colophon.
The colophon itself references the
date 1555, which may be a reference
to the date of the original
from which the scribe copied.
And a bit more enigmatic
is the reference to 1544,
"the fathers arrived," and
1552, "the book was completed."
We are not quite sure what these
references really refer to,
we are also not quite sure
whether we are reading it correctly
because these texts are
spelled with abbreviations.
So we're still studying this section
and don't really know whether these
earlier dates might actually refer
to an original compilation date.
So let's look at these various
sections of the handbook.
I talked about these Mayan numbers.
What's really special about
the Kislak manuscript is
that it has a unique list
of written Mayan numbers
which goes from 1 to 70 million.
And although we have sections on
Mayan numbers in other dictionaries
and grammars on highland
Mayan languages,
none of these go that high.
We've never seen something
going up that high.
We could identify the language,
these numbers are written in Ixil.
This is also very remarkable
because there's no other document
to our knowledge from the Colonian
era that is written in Ixil,
so this may be the only
document in Ixil language,
certainly from the 16th
century if not in general.
The analysis of the numbers
section is really interesting
as it provides us with
a very detailed example
of how counting works
not only in Ixil but also
in other highland Mayan languages
and this is also of general language
for Mesoamerican Studies because we
do understand the numbers system,
the arithmetics of
Mesoamerica quite well.
There has been, a lot of research
has been done in particular
on classic Maya culture, we
have here a picture of one page
of the codex, here's one of
the four surviving Mayan books
from the pre-Colombian
time, which is written
in Maya hieroglyphic writing and
full of calendrical information
and then astronomical information.
And we know since the very,
since the 19th century,
researchers like [inaudible]
and then in the 20th century
in particular, Sir Ed Thompson
and also Floyd Lounsbury have
produced tremendous detailed
information and analysis on how
calendrics and mathematics were
in the classic Maya system.
So we do understand that quite
well and I will give you a slide
for an introduction into this.
Maya accounting is based
on a vigesimal system.
Vigesimal is based on the number 20.
So our decimal system that we
are used to, as we all know,
is based on the number 10.
So you count in different steps
of, that are all multiplied by 10.
So one times 10 is 10, times
10 is 100, times 10 is 1,000
and these different cycles
are labeled with names
like a decade, a century,
a millennium.
And we notate this
and place notation
so when you see the number 1,983,
this means it's three times 10,
it's nine times 100,
and one times 1000.
And in the vigesimal system, that
works basically the same way,
it's just the basis is 20.
So you start with one and
you take that times 20 is 20,
times 20 is 400, times 20 is 8,000
times 20 is 160,000 times 20 is 3
million 200,000.
And each of these cycles in Mayan
languages has their own name
like we have decades and
centuries and millennium.
And... These names for these cycles
we do find in this Ixil document.
So we have special terms for the
numbers 20, which is "vinac,"
for the numbers 80, which is
"much-ul," for the numbers 400,
"o-much," which is
really interesting here
because the form itself only
occurs with higher numbers.
So we do find in the
text here under 800,
and I don't have a pointer, do I?
No. Oh, I do, okay.
Does that show?
Okay. So 800 is basically
written as two times 400,
400 itself doesn't
occur as one times 400,
it just occurs as four times 80.
So it's a very interact
counting system here.
We also have terms for the cycles of
8,000, "chuiul," 160,000, "calab,"
and 3 million 200,000, "tiche."
The Kislak manuscript is very
special in giving examples
for very complex high numbers as
you can see on this manuscript page.
For example, we have numbers
like 369,000, 381,000.
When we were looking
at this at first,
we had doubts whether this was
really a true Mayan numbers system
or whether this may have been
a scribe, a missionary trying
to translate European
numbers into Ixil.
But we have analyzed it and we find
that it is indeed a full Maya
vigesimal counting system
which functions the same way as
the classic Maya system does.
So as an example, the number
357,000 is written out as
"o-chuk-ul t-ox-la-oqob
t-o-chuy t-ox-kalab."
And that translates into five times
40 into the cycle of 14 times 400
into the cycle of five
times 8,000 into the cycle
of three times 160,000
which is the same
as 200 plus 4,800 plus 32,000 plus
320,000 which amounts to 357,000.
It is a bit complicated and
students of Maya studies,
Mesoamerican studies [inaudible]
a mess to get through this.
So I apologize for this being
a bit tedious in this talk.
But just to give you an idea
what we're dealing with here,
we have to be a bit mathematical.
And we are currently wrapping
up the results of our analysis
into an article and hope
that we get this written
and published very, very soon.
The next section is a
bit more easy to grasp.
Gary and I are also working on
this at high speed at the moment.
It's the section that regards
marriage prescription rules.
Very interesting.
You have several pages at
the end of the manuscript
which have these drawings
of these circles with names
in them and explanations.
And we first thought that
these were genealogies.
Because the form of representation
corresponds with what you find
in Renaissance Spanish or
also, up until the 19th century
in Spain, as family trees.
This is the way, how these
things are presented.
However, when we were translating
the associated K'iche' texts,
it was revealed that we are
not dealing with genealogies,
but with hypothetical or exemplary
drafts of kinship relations
and accompanying explanations
of what in Christian
or Spanish thought would be
understood as an illegitimate
or a legitimate sexual
relation or marriage taboos
and their respective
impact on legal inheritance.
To give you an example, this is
basically an easier visualized...
illustration of what we find
in the original manuscript.
So let me translate that for you.
"If Pedro has some illegitimate
relation with Maria," which means,
is spelled here in K'iche' as
"rach ajmak," "He is the companion
of the sinner," so he's
a sinner, that implicates
that this is an illegitimate
sexual relationship.
"If that is the case, then Pedro
must not marry either Maria's
daughter or her mother
or her grandmother,"
which is to European eyes, bizarre.
Why would somebody want to marry
the grandmother of a concubine?
It also says that, "Maria
must not marry Pedro's son."
So that's also forbidden.
Pedro's son, however, may
marry Maria's daughter
or her granddaughter.
So what we are thinking we
are dealing with here is
that these were drafts that were
used to teach the local population
about understandings of legitimate
marriage and inheritance rules
in Christian European society
which was the new cultural system
which was implemented by the
conquistadors and missionaries.
It may also reveal, the section
may also reveal indirect clues
about what was cultural
practice in highland Guatemala
because obviously the
missionaries saw a need
in making people understand
that they couldn't marry their
mother or their grandmother.
Which at first appears bizarre, but
it may not be that bizarre at all
because very often marriage
doesn't have anything to do
with sexual relations but with
making sure that somebody survives
and maintaining and
feeding somebody.
So in other cultures this,
the concept of marriage,
has different implications.
So we are working on that and we are
also drafting an article on this,
so you see there's a lot
of research that comes
out of this particular document.
But now finally to the text that
is really the focus of this talk,
and which is the oldest part of the
compilation of the [foreign term]
which dates to at least 1555.
And this text includes
songs or hymns
and is the reason why I gave
this talk the title that I chose,
"Songs of Faith and Devotion"
because it's really
about these songs.
They make a big section
of the manuscript.
So let's look at this.
The Spanish heading in
the original text reads,
"Beginning of the succession of
things regarding the Catholic faith
from the beginning to the
end in form of hymns or songs
so that the Indians would sing them
in their festivals or holidays."
The following paragraph in K'iche'
specifies that the text is a
"chanalibal vuh bixabal," "...is
a cantation book, and a bishop,"
a "vuh" or a songbook, "Which serves
the purpose of narrating the word
of God in form of songs
that shall be sung
at the annual Christian holidays."
If we look at the contents of this
text, the text spans from 17 recto
to 59 recto, so that's
more than 44 years
with very tiny writing,
as you can see here.
It comprises a total of 50
chapters and an additional 12 hymns.
And Gary was suggesting
that that may be related,
that 50 chapters might be
related to the weeks of the year,
that it is songs that are
sung in each week of the year.
Though we're still
working on establishing
that that is really the case.
Each section has a title,
or each chapter has a title
or a heading, which is in Spanish.
But the texts and the
songs are in K'iche'.
The chapters of variable length.
So some are just half a page and
others are several pages long.
They're divided into stanzas, which
you can see here in the image.
Which are marked by a
colonial-style paragraph sign, yeah.
Which divides the different stanzas.
And to give you an example for
the stanzas, we have now put them
into a more rhythmic pattern.
I read the first one in English,
"The truth I shall remember
and the faithfulness I shall
tell," and then literally,
"Much evil I feel for the fabricated
word," which is very metaphorical
in K'iche' means as much
as, "I despise the lie."
There are no indications that these
stanzas are following any kind
of old world model of
rhyme or metric system.
However, when you look at the
next stanza, "Oh, much I despise
that was lost the truth of being,
great is my tremble, my lament,
because it was lost
the truth of being."
You can see that, you can
see in this reputation here,
the "Great is my tremble, my
lament," "nim nucic, nim voeqel,"
that the author follows Maya poetics
by using couplets or parallelisms
and in this case, this particular
phrase, which is something
that we know from ingenious
language documents by Mayan authors,
and is a pattern which is
very well-known from the
"Theologia Indorum"
by Domingo de Vico
about which I will say
something in a few seconds.
If we look at the contents of the
chapters with their many stanzas,
we find detailed treaties of ethical
narratives including Genesis,
the fall of man, the banishment from
paradise, the division of language
at Babel, Sodom and Gomorrah, the
story of Moses, saint stories,
and of course the life of Jesus
from his birth to the passion,
including all miracles
and it's very detailed.
Based on the terminology
that is used in the text,
we can attribute authorship
clearly to the Dominican Order
or the Order of Preachers.
As I have shown, doctrinal
texts produced by Dominicans
in highland Guatemala
systematically adopt terminology
from highland Maya ritual
language, while Franciscan
and other authors prefer to
introduce their own words from Latin
and create neologisms or new terms.
There are certain key
terms that are indicative
for 16th century Dominican
doctrinal literature in Guatemala.
And these terms have today
been primarily associated
with Domingo de Vico's
"Theologia Indorum."
And this is where I have to mention
another project that is going
on at the moment and is
parallel to the work that Gary
and I are doing here on
the Kislak manuscript.
Which is a project that
is led by Gary Sparks
who actually is the utmost
authority on the "Theologia Indorum"
and Domingo de Vico in
the world, I would say.
It's a project which is headed
and led by him on the translation
of this particular document.
And I'm happy to be
part of this project.
The "Theologia Indorum" was the
first theology of the Americas
that was entirely written
in K'iche'.
It comprises two volumes
of 700 folios.
It's a very abundant source
and summarizes all basics
of the Christian faith written
for K'iche' speaking audience.
And this Domingo de Vico
incorporated a lot of terminology
and concepts from pre-Colombian
religion
to make the Christian concepts
understood to the K'iche' speakers.
And some of these terms that we
find in the "Theologia Indorum"
and that have been identified in
Gary's research, we now also find
in the Kislak manuscript, which
makes this Kislak source very,
very interesting for us because
we think it is earlier than the
"Theologia Indorum" and that
changes the picture a little bit.
So terms that are referenced
for example are
that the Christian god is referred
to as "Tz'aqol B'itol," the framer
and the former, which is a
reference to a Mayan creator god
that also occurs in
indigenous documents.
And he's referred to as "Dios
nim Ajaw," the great lord,
which is a term that according
to the "Apologetica Historia"
by Bartolome de las Casas, was used
before the arrival of the Spanish
to refer to the most
powerful creator deity.
It's, what's particularly
fascinating is something
that Gary pointed out
in his research,
that the Christian god is referred
to as "our mother and our father,"
which is a very Mayan concept.
Christian, we all know in
Christianity, god is male.
Yeah? God is not female.
In Maya thought it is both,
yeah, it is female and male.
And the female is always
referenced first.
Another concept which I have
done some work on is the concept
of "q'anal raxal," the abandons,
the green, the yellowness
and the greenness, which refers to
abandons from a rich maize harvest
and is a topic or a
concept that is used
in Maya religion, Maya
ritual terminology.
And it is here used
in order to refer
to the glory of the Christian god.
So there are several indications
here that we are dealing
with a Dominican source because
these are terms that are indicative
of Dominican translation practices.
With respect to the Dominican origin
of the text, it is also interesting
to note that the scribe
uses very unconventional
and not otherwise used
orthographic forms and letters
to represent the sounds of
the K'iche' phonetic system
that are not part of the
Spanish or the Latin alphabet.
He does not follow conventions
that are used by other missionaries
and that have been
established by the Franciscan,
Francisco de la Parra, which you
see in the box down here below.
Francisco de la Parra
defined that the [inaudible]
"k'" would be represented
by the sign "4."
And the [inaudible] "q " by what we
call "k," and the [inaudible] "q'"
by the turned around 3,
or the [foreign term].
And our scribe here uses
completely different conventions
to represent these sounds.
Which we interpret a little bit
as maybe that Dominicans were also
in these texts and were competing
with the Franciscan missionaries
because this really in
the very early stages
of when these conventions were
defined and that they said,
"We are not going to follow
Franciscan conventions,
we are doing our own
orthographic style."
So this is from that point
of view paleographically a very
interesting source as well.
The strongest connection to
Dominican authorship however comes
from the contents of the text.
In 1619, the Dominican chronicler
Antonio Remesal gives an account
of the peace for conquest of
Tezoatlan by Casas and his group
of friars that I mentioned before.
Tezoatlan, in today's K'iche'
speaking region of Guatemala,
had resisted the Spanish
invasion well into the 1530's.
And las Casas, when he heard
that there was another attempt
to conquer this region by
military force, he requested
and received permission from
the crown to conquer this region
by mission rather than by sword and
thereby end the terrible bloodshed
that had occurred in
highland Guatemala.
For this purpose, las Casas
recruited a team of [inaudible]
and linguistically versatile
Dominicans, who dedicated themselves
at writing doctrinal
texts for the mission
in the ingenious languages
of the region.
And text in Remesal
reads as follows,
"The friars were the friar
father Bartolome de las Casas,
father Rodrigo de Ladrada,
and friar Pedro de Angulo
and friar Luys Cancer.
All of them knew the language
of the province of Guatemala,
which includes all of Quiche
and Zacualpa very well.
And among them, they wrote
some strophes, or verses,
in a manner permitted
by the language
with their consonants and rhythms.
And in these they describe
the creation of the world,
the fall of man, his
banishment from paradise.
They included all the life and
miracles of Christ our lord,
his passion, his death,
his resurrection,
his ascension to heaven, and when
his second time will come again
to judge mankind and the end of
his coming, which is the punishment
of those who are evil and
reward for those who are good.
This work was a very long work and
as such, they divided it by pauses
and different verses in the
style of the Spanish ones,
which as these were the first to be
made in the language of the Indians,
deserve not to be forgotten for the
many more that were written later."
To summarize what Remesal says,
these writings were
the first translation
of the Christian doctrine into the
language of Guatemala by Dominicans.
It was a very comprehensive
and long work in form of songs
that were divided in
strophes or stanzas and,
and this is the most significant,
the contents correspond one-on-one,
including the order, with
the contents of the text
in the Kislak manuscript.
So what does Remesal tell
us about what happens
with these songs and these stanzas?
They were written, what
happened with them?
He goes on and he writes that
las Casas found four indigenous
merchants who traveled to
Tezoatlan on a regular basis
and were known to the local lot.
And Remesal writes that with care,
the friars taught these four
merchants, who had already converted
to Christianity, how to sing
these "coplas," or verses.
Las Casas then sent the merchants
to Tezoatlan to sing the songs
of Christianity to the people and
their [foreign term], or lord.
And Remesal writes, "The
merchants sang and preached
and all the people came
to hear the coplas.
Almost for eight days they
were singing about the creation
of the world, about the fall of man,
about the incarnation of Christ,
about the resurrection of Lazarus,
the merchants tried to sing a lot."
The songs and the music excited
the population of Tezoatlan
and the local lord and
they asked the merchants
to explain the contents
of the songs.
These then asked the lord to
invite the friars to explain
to them the contents of the faith.
The first friar who went to do this
was mentioned, friar Luys Cancer,
who went to Tezoatlan
and sang and preached.
And then as a result, the
lord converted to Christianity
and he signed a peace treaty
with the Spanish crown.
The province did not have to pay
any tribute or tax for several years
for accepting the king of Spain.
So that is basically the story
of the peaceful conquest
as told by Remesal.
Now you're already guessing it, is
that Gary and I assume that the text
in the Kislak manuscript is
a copy of these very coplas
that are mentioned by Remesal.
Which is exciting on its own.
But it's getting more complicated.
Because there's another
manuscript that has been identified
as the very text referred
to in Remesal.
And this is this one here from
the Newberry Library in Chicago,
which Basu [phonetic] suggested
to be this very coplas manuscript
that was written in Q'eqchi',
the language of the region
that was missionized by las Casas
and Cancer, and contains those songs
that were mentioned in the Remesal.
So at first, we thought
there's a problem here.
But when we looked at this in more
detail, we found that Basu is right.
Because we found that the Q'eqchi'
coplas that Basu wrote about
and the text in the Kislak
manuscript are two versions
of the same text, one in
Q'eqchi' and one in K'iche'.
And if we compare these two texts,
we can see that the Q'eqchi'
text is a bit more concise
and a bit more abstract
but in terms of contents,
both texts are identical.
Comparing it in more detail,
we see that the Kislak text
is far more comprehensive
and includes chapters and
hymns that are missing
in the manuscript from Chicago.
And in addition, the
individual chapters
in the Kislak manuscript
include more stanzas
and are much more detailed
in the K'iche' manuscript
than in the Q'eqchi' manuscript.
So this suggests the following.
We believe that we have
re-discovered the very coplas
that were mentioned in Remesal
in their original language
and we think it is K'iche'.
And thereby, we may have identified
the earliest doctrinal text
from highland Guatemala that
may originally go back as far
as into the 1530's, when las Casas
began his mission in the Verapaz.
So this document is in the Library
of Congress, it's a treasure here.
And with this, I would like to
thank you for your attention
and I'm happy to take questions.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible ]
That's a good question.
I know it was acquired by Arthur
Dunkelman [phonetic] on behalf
of Jay Kislak for the
Kislak collection
where it was originally was where
Arthur Dunkelman acquired it
and under which conditions
I don't know.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, the missionaries were really
taking a lot of care in thinking
about which terminology to use.
And when we compare the
doctrinal literature that we have
from highland Guatemala, we see
that it's not standardized at all.
It's very eclectic.
Missionaries from different orders
use different translation techniques
and different strategies.
And what we can see is that
there are particular differences
between Franciscans and Dominicans.
Franciscans prefer to use
neologisms, so the prime example
for this is that they
refuse to re-use any kind
of indigenous term for labeling god.
They would introduce
the Spanish term "dios."
And maybe change that to the
Mayan sound system a little bit
so it sounds like "kiosh."
Yeah, but they would not introduce
any indigenous terminology,
which is something that
the Dominicans did.
And they did that very deliberately.
And we can see that also in
documents from other Dominican
or areas in which the Dominicans
had a lot of missionary activity
like in Quechua documents
from the Andes.
Anna Dorsen [phonetic] has written
about those in quite a detailed way.
And yeah, we have very
different approaches here.
The Dominicans, this is what makes
the Dominican materials interesting.
And this is what makes highland
Guatemala a very interesting place
for researching the mission and
the production or the creation
of Christian terminology
and Christian concepts
in Mayan languages because
we have these two regions,
we have the K'iche' speaking region
and we have the Kaqchikel
speaking region,
two languages which are very similar
but the Kaqchikel region was mostly
dominated by Franciscan missionaries
and the K'iche' region
by Dominicans.
And they have very different
approaches to translation.
And you see in the Dominican
material all this re-use
of terminology and Gary has written
quite extensively about the re-use
of couplets and parallelism.
So Domingo de Vico is someone who
has adopted the ritual language
that was used in highland Guatemala,
and is used to the present day,
Mayan ceremonial specialists
use a specific form
of ceremonial discourse which
has a lot of parallelisms
and couplet structure and this
very couplet structure you find
in these Dominican documents.
And as I have to reference this
to Gary, I mean this is his work.
Just [inaudible].
[ Inaudible ]
I don't believe so.
I think, I don't where this is,
I must honestly say
I must blank on this.
I don't know whether this was a
strategy that missionaries had tried
in other parts of the world before.
But it was certainly very
successful and had a good effect
because Remesal writes
in much detail,
I mean I've given you a very short
account of this very detailed
and colorful description
that he has,
about how the people really loved
these songs and loved this music
and the harmonies and wanted
to learn how to sing those.
And they love the outfit
of the Dominican friars
with their shaved heads
and their black
and white gowns, which
were interesting.
It was just exotic, it
was something interesting.
And that probably did have the
mission, if you were confronted
with something that
you find exciting,
you're probably also interested
in learning more about it
so I think it was a very
successful strategy.
Wherever it came from, I don't know
whether it has been applied before.
[ Inaudible ]
I think this text was solely
compiled for the missionary himself.
We have originally called
him the highland Maya priest,
but we don't do this anymore
because we don't really know whether
it was really used by a priest
or by a missionary
of some other order.
But it was certainly something
that somebody, I mean,
because we have several texts,
eclectic different texts,
that were copied by the same hand.
So there was somebody in the
convent who probably sat down
and either copied this for himself
or had it copied for someone
to be used in the field,
to be used on his mission.
He probably carried this book
with him and these songs were,
likely these songs, these
original songs that were drafted,
and they had been sung, they had
been sung all over the highlands.
They were a part of the
general-- oh, I'm sorry--
of the general law that
was produced in order
to missionize and preach the gospel.
And every missionary who came into
highland Guatemala probably wanted
to know these songs and
thereby wanted a copy of it.
So this copy was probably
primarily for the missionary
so that he would have
this in writing,
since also all the
missionaries who came from Spain,
they had to learn the languages.
They came, they knew Spanish
and they obviously knew Latin
and maybe Greek, but they did not
know the highland Mayan languages.
So they came and they first learned
the languages and these handbooks
with all this material helped them
to learn and to memorize these songs
and sing them to the people
who could then repeat them.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, the region of
Tezoutlan was really fierce.
The people there really resisted
the conquest and the Spanish
and it took several attempts
to defeat this region
and always never succeeded.
But the conquests in the rest of
the regions had been so bloody,
that there was, in particular
from Bartolome de las Casas
and other missionaries, a
lot of resistance to this.
And I think the choice to use
merchants was a pragmatic one.
Because these were the only
people who could get in there.
I guess that the people in Tezoutlan
were so defensive the only people
who they would let in were
probably the merchants who came
from other provinces and knew the
languages and brought in products
from other highland Mayan areas
that were not necessarily
controlled by the Spanish.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.